hey this is pressure Locker I received
this problem by email because it's going
viral on Facebook with thousands of
people arguing about the correct answer
how smart are you a guy walked into a
store and steals a hundred-dollar bill
from the register without the owner's
knowledge he then buys
$70 worth of goods using the hundred
dollar bill and the owner gives $30 and
change how much money did the owner lose
was a thirty dollar seventy dollars a
hundred dollars one hundred thirty
dollars one hundred seventy dollars or
two hundred dollars can you figure it
out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the correct answer in some math problems
and in this story it helps to break the
problem down into different parts so at
first we'll only consider the first part
of the story a guy walks the new store
and feels a hundred dollar bill from the
register without the owner's knowledge
at this point how much does the owner
lose everyone agrees the owner loses a
hundred dollars the owner is minus 100
from the initial part of the story
so now let's separately consider just
the second part of the story
imagine someone buy $70 worth of goods
using a hundred dollar bill and the
owner gives $30 and change how much
would you say the owner has lost in just
this part of the story well if someone
buys $10 worth of goods using $100 bill
you would expect the owner to give $30
and change in fact the owner is
overseeing this transaction so the owner
here is not losing any money the owner
is you could say zero in this
transaction so now we put these two
stories together
the total loss will be the sum of these
two parts of the story we can add
negative 100 and zero to get that the
total loss is $100
the owner is negative 100 dollars from
before the story started so the correct
answer is the owner lost $100 now
there's one technicality if you want to
really overthink this problem and go
into the accounting details now when
someone buy 70 dollars worth of goods in
a store it's not because the goods are
worth $70 to the owner what happens here
is the owner is getting $100 bill and
gives back 30 dollars and change but the
goods have some value V this is usually
going to be less than $70 so you could
say the owner is actually losing the
value of the goods but then getting
annexed $70 because it's $100 bill - the
$30 and change so here the owner loses V
minus 70 or you could say the owner is
70 minus V in terms of the cash position
so if you were to take these two stories
now you add up the results
the owner ultimately loses $30 plus the
value V of the good so if we assume the
value V is 70 dollars which you say $70
worth of goods then you would say the
owner lost $100 you could still arrive
at the same answer of $100 but this is a
little more accurate in terms of pure
accounting so why are so many people
getting the problem wrong well one of
the common answers is there is a 200
dollar loss to the owner many people are
saying this is because in the first part
of the story the owner loses a hundred
dollars that's stolen and then in the
second part of the story the owner loses
another hundred dollars because the
owner is giving up seven dollars worth
of goods and $30 and change so the
mistake here is that it's not taking a
new account the owner is also getting a
hundred dollar bill so when you take
that other part of the story where you
get the hundred dollar bill that will
just the total by +100 and when you do
that that means the owner ultimately
lost $100 in total
another common answer is that the owner
had $130 loss this is from the stolen
hundred dollar bill and the thirty
dollars and change
well the problem with this answer is
it's not taking account that the owner
also gave up $70 in goods but also got a
hundred dollar bill so when you take
into account these transactions the net
result would be the owner losing $100
which is negative 100
so to summarize most of the incorrect
responses either didn't add or subtract
the numbers correctly or they didn't
take into account every transaction it
seems the fact that in the second half
of the story the person used the stolen
dollar bill somehow people don't treat
that as a genuine hundred dollar bill
that is $100 that the owner is getting
back when you take into account every
single transaction and you treat it
correctly as either a loss or a gain for
the owner you end up that the owner lost
$100 did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker if you liked this video please
check out my book there are links in the
video description